four different people who are all known
as Candyman but if you think about it
this tends to be how real urban legends
go as the story is passed from
generation to generation details get
changed and bias from each time period
Creeps in it's not that different from
the Legend of Bloody Mary depending on
who you ask today people might tell you
that Bloody Mary is one of a number of
people including Queen Mary the first of
England an American serial killer named
Mary worth Hungarian serial killer ctis
Elizabeth b or even a Sal and witch
trial victim named Mary from the early
modern era I honestly don't know how
Elizabeth B's name got in the mix
because her name isn't even Mary it
might just be one of those things where
two different urban legends merge with
the passage of time much like Sherman
fields and Daniel robotti as retellings
continually reshape a story you end up
with different versions that have
different detail in telephone you start
with one phrase and each kid Whispers it
to the kid next to them and once you get
all the way around the circle the
original phrase is often changed
entirely